hi my name is Lisa Raye and I'm on the
Android developer relations team today
I'm going to be talking about the
storage API in Android 4.4
so let's get started before KitKat you
may have seen or implemented something
like this you had action get content or
action pick and you declared one or more
intent filters in an activity in your
manifest and this is what it looked like
you would pick one app and you would get
one file back in your original
application in KitKat we've introduced a
beautiful new picker UI owned by the
system you can browse content from all
apps not just one you can see recent
files across all apps and you can search
within an app you can edit and save
files in place and it supports
traditional file hierarchies but it's
flexible enough for tag based cloud
storage and finally it supports multiple
user accounts or transient routes like a
USB storage provider where it should
only show up when the drive is plugged
in in the storage API we've introduced
two new intents open doc and create doc
get content and pics still work and
we've added a new permission manage
documents which only the system can hold
so how to implement this first of all in
your manifest set your target SDK to 19
next add your provider your provider
name in the manifest is the name of your
Java class for your content provider
mine is called my cloud provider name
your authority your package name plus
provider your provider should be
exported because you want other
applications to see it namely the system
also add the manage documents permission
my default ur provider is available
everyone adding the manage documents
permission restricts your provider to
the system important for security also
we've added intent filters to providers
make sure yours has the documents
provider action so it shows up when the
system searches for document providers
here's a quick picture of the flow as
you can see providers and clients don't
interact directly just as before a
client request permission to interact
with files read edit create etc the
system picker goes to each registered
provider and
the user the matching content routes one
more note before we get into the
provider usually with content providers
you have to make your own contract
document in this case it's done for you
all the constants for fields you might
return and a lot of other really useful
methods are in the class documents
contract here these are the columns
we're going to return in a cursor when
we're queried for documents or the route
how you implement a provider you must
extend documents provider it's an
abstract class and it has a minimum for
methods you must implement yourself
they're called in this order query
routes followed by query child documents
and finally possibly either query
document or open document there's many
more but we're going to start with the
most simple case which is just
supporting open doc here's an example of
what happens when the provider first
queries the roots of all document
providers the projection you see as an
argument just represents the specific
fields the caller wants to get back
resolved route projection is a method
that returns either those fields or the
full projection if the caller passed in
no so here we're creating a new cursor
and we're adding one row to it one route
a top-level directory like gallery or
drive most applications will have one
route you might have more than one in
the case of say multiple user accounts
in that case just add a second row to
the cursor the one thing that's not
given here is get document ID for file
your implementation is going to depend
on how you structure your file storage
what's important is that every file
including directories have exactly one
unique ID other apps might hold on to
this ID and it's explicit part of the
contract that it won't change
here's what shows up when you query
children this method gets called when
you choose an applications route in the
picker UI it gets the child's done the
child documents of a directory it can be
called every level in the file hierarchy
not just the route this simple
implementation is very simple it makes a
new cursor with the requested columns
and then it adds information about every
immediate child in the parent directory
to the cursor include file is very
similar to what we just saw for the
route it adds the files display name
mind type size and so forth a child can
be an image another directory any type
of file
so query document one or both a query
document or open document will get
called when the user selects a document
query document returns the same
information that was passed in query
child documents but just that specific
file just the one of them open document
returns a parcel file descriptor which
another application can use to stream
data you can see that we're setting the
access mode and the system takes care of
issuing URI permission grants for us
those first four are enough to get your
content provider up and running but
there are a lot more methods you can
override recent documents search add
thumbnails to your images your
implementation of these may vary
significantly depending on what kind of
back-end you're running I'm not going to
go over them all here but there's a
sample implementation of each of these
methods in the source code I'm posting
one more thing security is often a large
issue when you're sharing documents
suppose you are a password-protected
cloud storage service and you want to
make sure the user is logged in before
you start sharing their files I'm
assuming you have some existing method
of authenticating the user if not I
recommend Google+ integration in any
case you're starting your user is not
logged in what you do in your content
provider is to return 0 roots that is an
empty root cursor it might be important
if your user had been logged in
previously and you had been providing a
root full of documents now you don't
want to the other step to this is to
call get content resolver notify change
remember the documents contract we're
using it to make this URI this tells the
system to query the roots of our
provider again which will return a
different value now because of the if
statement we just saw so sample code and
slides will be available in look in the
description of the video for a link
thanks for watching and let's share some
documents